the white house is keeping a close eye
on ukraine as about a 100 000 russian
troops sit at russia's border with
ukraine and while diplomacy is the
preferred solution president biden today
spoke in plain language on the
consequences russia would face if
vladimir putin were to direct a move on
ukraine
if any
any assembled russian units move across
ukrainian border
that is an invasion
but it will be met with severe and
coordinated economic response that i've
discussed in detail with our allies as
well as laid out very clearly for
president putin
but there is no doubt let there be no
doubt at all that if putin makes this
choice russia will pay a heavy price
all right so given biden's remarks we
also want to talk about what russia's
strategy is here and what might play out
if russian forces do cross the ukrainian
border so joining us to discuss is
melinda herring deputy director of the
atlantic council's eurasia center
melinda welcome to quick take you
obviously just heard this conversation
with president biden saying that russia
will pay a heavy price do you think his
remarks uh made things worse
no i think that
the kremlin's just going to shrug his
shoulders uh president biden has made a
lot of statements he told the kremlin
that he will do three things if they
invade ukraine again you will see the
meanest nastiest package of sanctions
that we've ever thrown at you you will
see more defensive material in ukraine
and you will see more nato troops in
eastern europe so i don't think this is
anything new he's using you know he's
trying to scare putin uh the question is
has he
does moscow fear this package of
sanctions i don't know that it does
did he misspeak though because the white
house is trying to walk things back a
little bit here
joe biden really screwed up last night
he made a statement and he took off his
presidential hat and he put on his think
tank cap he was trying to do my job he
was trying to analyze the situation and
he made a number of screw-ups he said he
thinks that putin is going to go in he
said that there's different scenarios uh
he said that there would be different
responses he talked about differences
between the allies this is no no no no
no the white house immediately tried to
step it back and issue you know a
regular talking points that you would
expect the white house uh to issue that
we have ukraine's back that our position
hasn't changed but you know putting um
say he basically seeded the initiative
to putin and said that the ball is in
your court uh and that's a really
dangerous place to be in but it's not
game over scarlet there's a chance that
the white house could uh pull back that
initiative if they do something really
smart what do they need to do they need
to push nato to put troops in eastern
europe right now before vladimir putin
does anything more serious and then also
to keep sending defensive material to
ukraine now that that's what would
convince putin that the u.s is serious
about deterrence what do you think the
likelihood is of the us successfully
pushing nato on getting troops on the
ground there given that the u.s has said
we we won't be sending troops ourselves
i think nato is open to it there's
discussions right now
that are underway and i think it's a
real possibility if the white house
stands up and shows leadership on this
issue today
you know one thing about this whole
situation is we've been here before it's
been a while right because russian
troops have been gathering at the
ukraine border since november why is the
u.s why is the ukraine so convinced that
putin will be moving the troops across
the border by late january early
february when they could stay there
indefinitely
they can't stay there indefinitely that
that's one uh problem that i'd like to
correct so in order to keep these troops
there it takes a lot of money and
material and they can't stay um at these
at these temporary bases you know
forever and ever there's a limited time
window uh the weather is not on putin's
side it has been a
uh it's been a mild winter and if he
wants to do a full land scale invasion
he needs he needs the the mud to freeze
so that the tanks can roll in but you
know what i i just got off the phone
with some folks in kiev and they've said
that you all in washington need to calm
down vladimir putin is not doing a land
invasion anytime soon uh the latest
number from ukraine uh my ukrainian uh
defense people say that there are 120
000 to and forty thousand russian troops
and they're in the north they're in the
east and they're in the south so they
surround ukraine by three sides but if
you wanted to do a full-scale land
invasion you would need at least 200 000
troops but 300 000 would be more
preferable and the russians aren't doing
the things that you would need to do
they are putting the logistics staff in
place right now if if they were planning
a full-scale land invasion so
he also said watch
the movement of people and watch the
movement of fuel these are two things
that military analysts will be watching
in the weeks to come
that's so interesting that's so
interesting that they said that you guys
are misunderstanding a lot of this what
else are we misunderstanding in the us
when it comes to putin's intentions and
and how things appear
so i i think we underestimate him at
first i thought this conflict was all
about ukraine i thought vladimir putin
wants to destroy the western project but
this is a lot this is about much more
than ukraine ukraine is a lever putin
wants to destroy nato he wants to make
the west look weak and he wants to
rewrite the the the rules of the
european security architecture so when
we want to just sort of ignore this
problem and go back to trying to fix
covid or thinking about climate change
or some of the other administration's
priorities we can't vladimir putin is
not going away even if we want to ignore
him he is super ambitious and he's not
going to be satisfied even if he gets
what he wants in ukraine given that what
would you say is the role of the rest of
europe here
europe needs to step up that that's
that's the issue uh the germans have
refused to sell weapons to ukraine knock
it off
it's obvious that the ukrainians need
weapons and they need support ukraine uh
europe needs to speak in a unified voice
it needs to send as much material as it
can and it needs to maintain its unity
that that's the really crucial point
right now and it can't sell ukraine out
it cannot engage in any kind of deal
that we will protect our security in
place of ukraine that's what russia
wants russia wants uh europe to trade
ukraine away that that is a no-go
it very much feels like a chess match
between joe biden who often misspeaks on
this as we've seen and vladimir putin
who you've just mentioned we tend to
underestimate
we know that a bipartisan delegation of
senators traveled to ukraine over the
weekend to try to reassure kiev that the
u.s stood by and stood with them is
there a role for other groups to play
here or does it really come down to how
biden and putin decide on their next
step
that's a great question so vladimir
putin wants to narrow the negotiating
table he wants the table to be vladimir
putin and joe biden but if biden was
smart last week he kept expanding it so
we had the osce we had nato involved you
can't decide ukraine's future without
europe and without the ukrainians and
that's a point the white house has been
really really consistent on and i i i
would applaud them for that
i'm a little curious as well just about
the individuals living in ukraine
melinda how concerned are you for for
them
do you see this becoming you know a
situation like anything else that we've
seen uh the biden administration
handling in terms of foreign policy
efforts to help other nations handle
human rights abuses if things get to
that point
so the mood in kiev is very different
than it is in washington i live in
washington and it's ukraine ukraine
ukraine all the time right now it's the
biggest crisis
and i think the white house deserves
credit uh for
uh getting europe and ukraine uh waking
everyone up and saying guys this is
really a big crisis it could spiral into
a world war and that's i'm saying that
without exaggeration it really could um
but ukrainians feel differently uh i
have a stringer in kiev now he just
wrote a wonderful piece for the atlantic
council website his name is vladislav
davidson and he says that people either
don't want to talk about it hey we've
been at war for eight years
nothing new or they have a sense of
fatalism if russia's going to attack
it's going to attack so
the mood in kiev is is really one um
that you that i certainly didn't expect
it's a mix of denial and fatalism
that is so interesting i i go back to
what maddie had said earlier which is
the u.s made clear that u.s troops would
not be called in but do you see any
scenario melinda in which the u.s
military might be called in to to take
on what's happening in the ukraine and
with russia
i don't think that joe biden
can afford politically to send troops
there and he he said it's no way but
there are other things that we could do
we can send more trainers uh we can send
more ships uh there's a number of things
that we could do to bolster ukraine uh
and to show that we're serious about
deterrence short of sending boots on the
ground
when a final question for you you
mentioned that you're in washington and
that this is the topic of the hour of
the day long term do you think that this
is going to be domestically a voting
issue and at the ballot issue a kitchen
table issue for voters and and is that
perhaps why biden is pushing it so much
right now
yes and no so this is an election year
and joe biden's numbers are sliding
right and he had a big screw-up in
afghanistan he cannot afford another
major foreign policy blunder remember
joe biden was mr senate foreign
relations committee he has a lot of
expertise on foreign policy so he really
can't uh afford another screw-up and
covet hasn't gone well and the economy
hasn't turned around so uh you know his
he's he's got to get this one right and
he also has a personal stake in in
ukraine you have to remember this when
he was vice president he was negotiating
he was going back and forth all the time
he really really cares about how things
land in ukraine he wants ukraine to
succeed so i think he has a personal
stake and politically he's got to get it
right
it's a lot of things that he has to get
right then melinda thank you so much for
the context on the situation escalating
in ukraine melinda herring is deputy
director of the atlantic council's
eurasia center